tonight this is the real deal we are now
inching closer and closer to truth and
to justice and we're holding those that
abuse power accountable for two years on
this program and we have watched a
political persecution all based on lies
and a hoax driven by antitrump hatred
and literally wrecking the very fabric
of our society we have massive
developments tonight on many fronts the
Attorney General bar went before the
Senate Appropriations Committee today
and the boomerang I've been telling you
about is now in motion it is headed
right back in the direction I told you
it would head and we also have a brand
new just released today closed-door
testimony from the general counsel the
FBI under Comey and it is full of
massive examples of upper echelon FBI
DOJ abuse of power and also just
breaking moments ago multiple outlets
including the Wall Street Journal
reporting Greg Craig the White House
Counsel for Barack Obama expects to be
indicted over his work in Ukraine we'll
have more on that in a moment
also we begin with our Hannity truth
watch with a question how did all this
happen how did it all begin
we've got to get to the bottom of this
or we'll never have equal justice an
equal application of our laws future
elections and yes potential presidential
deep state coos will occur now today the
Attorney General he delivered a
bombshell development during his
testimony before the Senate
Appropriations Committee exactly what
we've been telling you for over two
years is true take a look
yes I think spying did occur well let me
question is whether it was predicated
adequately predicated and I'm not
suggesting it wasn't adequately
predicated but I need to explore that I
think it's my obligation Congress is
usually very concerned about
intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agencies staying in their
proper Lane and I want to make sure that
happened we have a lot of rules about
that and I want to say that that
I said I'm reviewing this I am going I
haven't set up a team yet but I do have
I have in mind having some colleagues
help me pull all this information
together and let me know whether there's
some areas it should be looked at this
is downright scary every single American
it's not political it's not Democrat
Republican blue red is not about
politics we give our law enforcement
officials our intelligence officials the
most powerful tools of intelligence they
are never to be weaponized against we
the American people much less a
political campaign at the height of an
election or to undo an election where
are all these civil libertarians on the
Left where are the liberals calling for
investigations
he got Nadler Schumer Schumer Blumenthal
they're freaking out tonight they're
calling the Attorney General they're
calling on him to retract his true full
remarks they clearly can't handle the
truth speaker Pelosi said Barr was off
the rails
ajan Pelosi said that about someone else
funny let me just say how very very
dismaying and disappointing that the
chief law enforcement officer of our
country is going off the rails
he is the Attorney General of the United
States of America not the Attorney
General of Donald Trump well apparently
she and other Democrats they don't want
bar to perform the proper oversight and
follow the law and the DOJ and the FBI
which is his job they who advanced the
Trump witch-hunt they who lied for years
are exposed as the frauds that they are
they don't want the truth and the
mainstream media they're trying their
very best to play down all the
bombshells we have tonight Washington
Post fake conservative writer Jennifer
Rubin actually calling on Barr to be
impeached her fellow far-left conspiracy
sycophants at at MSNBC tinfoil hat
conspiracy theory MSNBC fake news CNN
also trashing the Attorney General she
didn't do that to rod Rosenstein or
Muller take a look
I spy an attorney general giving
credence to conspiracy theories it feels
like we that basically the Attorney
General gasps let the country bill bar
one of our nation's most respected
lawyers a two-time attorney general turn
in his tortoiseshell glasses for a
tinfoil hat Bar has made really clear
I'm gonna be an engine for the President
of the United States I am NOT the
Attorney General for the country the
Attorney General of the United States in
a dog whistle - Sean Hannity is a big
deal he is a flunky for Donald Trump
he's not an independent thinker he
sounds good
he seems sincere but if you look at what
he does not what he says
then you see the actions of a hatchet
man here and it's really disturbing
conspiracy theorists for two and a half
years lying the very people that lied
for two and a half years they don't want
their tin foil hat conspiracy theories
their lies exposed they've been pushing
it every second every hour every minute
of every day including their coverage of
this very topic just a few months ago
take a look at this what we've seen and
heard from the president in the past
five days may be the biggest lie of all
repeatedly and with no facts to back him
up making the outrageous claim that the
so-called deep state spied on his
campaign this phony baloneys story about
a spy in the campaign to call them a
conspiracy theory is to give them too
much credit notion that somehow the FBI
implanted planted someone inside the
campaign to spy on the campaign is just
not true this unproven narrative of a
spy being placed inside his campaign did
the intelligence community spy on
President Trump in his campaign no we
did not they did and they've been lying
for two and a half years and lying to
you the American people President Trump
was right all along
we were right all along they have no
character no ethics no integrity they
should be apologizing retracting
correcting all the damage they have done
they just double down online and the
media the Democrats they are so blinded
by this hate this rage they are
incapable of seeing this
cold truth right before their eyes let's
look at this July 2016 we know the FBI
opened up a counterintelligence
investigation into the Trump campaign
aides George papadopolis after he spoke
with an informant maybe even before this
we know in that same month the FBI
attempted a wiretap campaign associate
Carter page for no good reason
we know that in July 2016 top Obama
officials including Susan Rice the Year
2016 they ramped up their unmasking
efforts a whopping 350 percent a final
year the election year in October 2016
the FBI began successfully spying on
Carter page after getting that FISA
warrant by committing a fraud on
multiple levels to the FISA Court using
Clinton's bought and paid for Russian
lies they never told the judges that the
bulk of information were unverified
uncorroborated information paid for by
hillary and guess what they denied an
American citizen his constitutional
rights and they got their backdoor right
into the Trump campaign through Carter
page and in December 15th of 2016 we
know the Obama of officials oh they just
incidentally spied on Trump officials
after rice well she reportedly amassed
the names of Steve ban and Jared Kushner
Lieutenant General 33-year veteran yeah
there was spying as we have reported
rightly so many many times now sadly
that's only one small part of this abuse
of power and corruption now throughout
the night we're going to show you the
full timeline we've reported everything
but guess what after months and months
of waiting truth and justice and facts
in spite of all of them are now
beginning to come cascading down and
we'll drown the proper people criminal
referrals the Horowitz report the Hoover
report the release of more closed-door
testimony yeah we'll get those FISA
applications gang of eight materials
302s we're waiting on a florida court to
release information on Christopher
Steele that should be very revealing and
enlightening and an answer to this
important question
would it be odd that the candidate was
never really briefed by the Department
of Justice that your campaign may be
targeted by a foreign entity that is one
of the questions I have is no I feel
normally the campaign would have been
advised of this okay and can you think
of a good reason right now while they
wouldn't have been I'm interested in
getting that answer they had two former
US attorneys in Chris Christie and and
Rudy Giuliani involved in the campaign
and I don't understand why the campaign
was not advised clearly there was
extreme corruption by a powerful few at
the highest level of our government the
evidence of this is riddled throughout
the now public transcript of the Baker
testimony today congressman Doug Collins
released yet a second day of closed-door
testimony from the FBI's former top
lawyer tonight we're learning very
revealing brand-new bombshells according
to Baker the DOJ was having open
discussions about appointing an
independent counsel to investigate the
Trump campaign long before call me was
fired quote I don't even remember who
said it quite honestly but I'm telling
you that the topic did come up before
the firing now wait we are told that the
eight days in May
well after Comey was fired that's what
triggered the special counsel well as it
turns out it was in the works all along
why because call me McCabe struck page
and all these other deep state officials
that thought Hillary should win a
hundred million to zero and that we're
all smelly Walmart people that that are
going to vote for Trump they were
desperate to remove Trump from office
remember they had an insurance policy in
fact Baker alleging that McCabe page Rod
Rosenstein were discussing removing
President Trump
undoing an election by using the 25th
amendment
they even allegedly bragging that they
had to administration cabinet members on
board with this scheme this plot this
coup no joking matter
Baker testified quote I took it
seriously because my assessment was that
they took it seriously Baker also
revealed that rod Rosenstein offered to
wear that wire and spy on the President
of the United States without cause
and that no one alerted the president or
anyone else about this illegal plot and
keep in mind prior to Trump's
inauguration James Baker was fed Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier by liberal reporter
David corn and a lawyer associated with
the Clinton campaign now the contents of
the dossier dossier were being passed
around at the highest levels of the DOJ
FBI Intel community around the same time
the Clinton was cleared of all charges
Baker testified he thought Hillary
Clinton should have been indicted he's
the top lawyer under Comey
quote I had that belief initially after
reviewing a large binder of her emails
that had classified information in the
that is a violation 18 USC 793 that's
the Espionage Act Baker said he was
persuaded out of it by his colleagues
now they wanted the Clinton matter swept
under the rug
even page and struck said yeah the fix
was in you know they're there but it's
gone all the decisions are made by
Loretta Lynch and the Democrats at the
Department of Justice now look at our
new timeline how did we get to this
point let's start July 10 2015 FBI
opened a criminal investigation
codenamed mid-year exam into Hillary
Clinton's handling of classified
information on that private server
September 2015 Obama's AG Loretta Lynch
asked the FBI director Comey to refer to
Clinton's criminal investigation not as
the investigation it is but as a matter
on March 4th 2016 top FBI officials
struck page they're busy texting about
their utter contempt for Donald Trump
one time calling Donald Trump an idiot
saying that Clinton should win Oh a
hundred million is zero and that we're
smelly Walmart voters of Trump and in
March of second may 2nd rather of 2016
Comey struck others drafting a letter
exonerating Hillary changing the
language from gross negligence the legal
standard to extreme carelessness which
it is not before they ever investigated
or interviewed Hillary and then on June
27 2016 that's when Lynch met Bill
Clinton in a secret meeting and a prior
plane in a tarmac in Phoenix July 2nd
2016 two months after the beginning of
the exoneration other key witnesses
Hillary Clinton finally interviewed by
Peter struck who hates Trump another FBI
agent and on July 5th call me officially
exonerates clinton in that very same
month then the FBI opens a
counterintelligence investigation into
Trump Russia collusion that one's called
crossfire hurricane in the very same
month an associate Deputy Attorney
General Bruce or meets with Christopher
Steele of multiple occasions but his
wife Nellie well works with Steele in
August or shares the contents of
Steele's dirty Russian dossier with
McCabe struck page even Andrew Weissman
and others or warns them that the
dossier is campaign op research tainted
with bias it's not verified Hillary paid
for it in Steele hates Trump in July
one-time CIA operative Stephan helper
reportedly meets with Trump advisers
page George papadopolis secretly
gathering information for the FBI then
on August 15th again 2016 before the
election struck tex lisa page about a
scenario where trump's get gets elected
quote we can't take that risk and they
speak of needing the insurance policy
september 2nd 2016 page instruct text
the president obama wants to know
everything we are doing october 22nd
2016 well that's when the FBI obtained
the FISA warrant to surveil trump
campaign
associate carter page the bulk of the
application relying on Steele's dirty
dossier with russian lies paid for by
hillary Wow a whole entry into the
entire world of Donald Trump and his
campaign on November 1st 2016
FBI fires Christopher Steele for lying
and leaking December 15th Trump as
president-elect Obama Intel officials
incidentally quote spy on Trump
officials Obama National Security
Advisor Susan Rice reportedly unmasking
the names of Bannon Kushner and general
Flynn January 2017 Comey briefed the
president that the dossier
was Laois as' and unverified but on
october well he signed the first FISA
warrant may 9 27 teen the president
fired FBI director Comey making Trump
Haider Andrew McCabe the acting FBI
director he's friends with page and
struck may 17 27 teen rod Rosenstein de
pointes robert muller special counsel
mauler immediately higher struck
Weissman Jeanne Ray Weissman of course
was at the Clinton victory party jeanne
ray the attorney for the Clinton
Foundation's and all Democrats and dem
donors to lead the investigation the
majority of the staff big time
Democratic donors zero Republicans hired
June 8th 2017 former FBI director Comey
admits having engineered a leak of his
own memo to the New York Times to spur
the appointment of the special counsel
flash-forward March 22nd this year
nearly two years thirty million dollars
later no collusion no obstruction
nothing the evidence is clear the
president was set up by a powerful group
of unelected individuals desperate to
stop him getting elected and helped his
opponent Hillary Clinton get elected and
then tried to destroy him after the
election